100 years ago when the modern Turkish
Republic was founded it was built on the
ashes of what was the Ottoman Empire in
this Century turkey has transformed
itself politically economically
militarily it prided itself in exporting
its drones its military hardware and
defending its own territory and also the
role of the military which was involved
in so many coups in this country has
also been curtailed where now there is a
democratic government in place a
succession of democracy in place and
politicians are no longer threatened by
generals but by the
elector my citizens we achieved great
things in such a short time the greatest
of these is the Republic of Turkey whose
Foundation is Turkish heroism and
tanding Turkish culture 100 years ago
Mustafa Kamal Turk envisioned a western
aligned a non Arabic script writing a
country which was more secular but now a
lot has changed in the last 100 years
there is a country which is trying to
find its roots between religious
conservatism and secularism but
celebrations and Gatherings there are
muted because the events taking place in
Gaza we maintain a Firm Stance for
Palestine and Gaza which OT Turks said
no one can touch and in that stride we
try to help the people of
Gaza the bosphorous straight divides
turkey between Asia and Europe in the
last 100 years turkey has repositioned
itself with close ties to Asia while
becoming a member of the North Atlantic
Treaty Organization or NATO and in The
Next Century as turkey's President says
is going to be turkey Century people are
optimistic and hopeful but there is a
caveat they want the government to
ensure that there is political stability
and economic
Prosperity ist